foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists what if there was a
minimalism checklist that helped you
live a simpler life finally we found one
and as we're talking about today on this
public edition of the minimalist podcast
then this Thursday on the minimalist
private podcast Ryan and I are going to
record an entire episode about one of my
favorite subjects minimalist
architecture you can check that out at
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100
advertisement free Ryan before we get to
our questions today I wanted to pull up
this minimalism checklist and then I'll
read some of it to you here this is from
our friend Joshua Becker's website
becoming minimalist.com it's a guest
post from Melissa Wilkins and Melissa
has this checklist of becoming a
minimalist and so when you want to seek
minimalism if you're thinking about
becoming a minimalist what is what are
some of the things to consider so I'm
not going to read the entire article
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
so you you can follow along if you'd
like you can read the entire thing but
this is the minimalism checklist that
she put together number one Ryan what is
your why
or how might your life look better with
less exactly yeah awesome in fact so
Ryan and I often when people ask we're
doing media interviews or whatever where
do we start and people often think well
we you start in your attic or your
garage or your basement whatever right
and those things can all be helpful but
really starting with the why how might
your life be better with less asking
that question helps you uncover the
purpose behind simplifying yeah number
two on the list here is start with easy
I really screwed this one up Ryan yeah
me too I could have done so much better
if I started with the easy stuff but
instead I started with the most
difficult things what are the most
difficult things
well I mean in your case it would be
your uh Mother's things who had just
passed yes sentimental items yeah
exactly so I didn't even know about
minimalism at the time oh Jordan can we
start our timer over here by the way
thank you
um I didn't know about minimalism at the
time I started simplifying my mom's
stuff when she passed and that was not
easy at all yeah I looked around all her
things and I wanted to cling to all of
it because it was all sentimental to me
but of course if everything is
sentimental then nothing is sentimental
right and as much as we want to cling
what are we doing we're just putting as
our friend Dr John deloney says we're
sort of just putting bricks in our
backpack and it's almost like I went
down to Florida to deal with my mom's
stuff to really just grab all of the
bricks that she had accumulated over her
life and bring them back into my life
yeah yeah I didn't start with the easy
stuff either I mean I packed up my
entire house yeah that I mean the
packing party was crazy but you know
what though when you kind of came up
with that idea
um I knew that it was gonna help me
change my state and like hold on real
quick go for it I didn't come up with
the idea complex I came with half the
idea I came with the packing part yes
and I came up with the Party part yes I
was uh mimicking Colin Wright's breakup
party that's right
um but yeah man I mean I that almost was
the
it was the easy way to change my state
or it was maybe this simple maybe that's
the way looking at it it was a simple
way to change my state but it was not
easy I mean it took us 10 hours to like
pack everything up and unpacking was
kind of a pain in the butt um I wish I
would get I mean I knew what was in the
boxes everything was marked real nice
um but they were just kind of like all
stacked in a cube and digging for things
was kind of a pain in the butt but yeah
ultimately it worked out we wrote about
it and here we are 11 years later almost
I think it's almost 13 years later oh
yeah yeah
12 years later yeah so old
foreign
now that you're watching the YouTube
version thankfully Austin and Jordan are
color correcting this whole episode they
put the D aging filter on you yeah yeah
it's a giant Instagram filter oh my God
we're basically catfishing you if you're
watching the YouTube version some of
those filters are crazy I bet you could
find a de-aging filter anyway that would
look insane well didn't they do that in
one of those uh the Scorsese film the
Irishman yeah the Irishman it looked
like an Instagram filter throughout the
film yes it did anyway starting with the
easy one way to do that is the 30-day
minimalism game yeah which was sort of
an amalgamation of what you did and what
I did when I simplified my life when I
simplified my life it was what if I got
rid of one item just one each day for a
month what would happen well I end up
getting way more than 30 items because
you get that momentum you have to start
with something easy just find anything
and then your packing party was a bit
extreme so it was like how do we meet in
the middle here in the 30-day minimalism
game was the way to do that so you
partner up with a friend a family member
A co-worker beginning of the month you
make a bet you bet a dollar or a million
dollars or anything else you want to bet
and you decide hey over the month we're
gonna get rid of some stuff first day of
the month we each get rid of one item
second day of the month we each get rid
of two items it starts off really easy
but by the middle of the month for me it
started to get difficult around day 12.
every time I've played it yeah oh a
dozen things today and then a Baker's
Dozen tomorrow yeah yeah no Mariah and I
are playing it this month and like yeah
today's day 16 and like started getting
hard around yeah day 14 or 15 where it's
like oh no now I gotta I got it yeah
anyway so I don't know if we're gonna
make it to the end of the month but it
definitely gets difficult around that
time for sure well we'll see who wins
and then I'm sure I know Mariah if she
wins yeah I guess you have to like
streak around the neighborhood nude
we're playing together oh so you both
have to go around the neighborhood we're
playing against ourselves yes exactly
make sure you film that Danny
but all right
anyway if you want to download our free
minimalism game calendar you can see all
the rules and the terms and conditions
just kidding there are no terms or
conditions it's free to play but you can
download the free minimalism game
calendar over at the minimalists.com
game number three on the minimalism
checklist Ryan is separate once and
needs now you and I would call this junk
and Essentials I would add one other
category in there non-essentials yeah so
the other way I would look at that is
need want and like right or essential
non-essential but value-adding and junk
yeah so in our minimalist rulebook which
you can download for free at the
minimalists.com rulebook we have 16
rules for living with less one of them
is the No Junk Rule and the No Junk rule
says everything you own even if you own
a hundred thousand items a million items
everything you own or everything you're
thinking about owning can fit into one
of three piles yeah it's either
essential
it's non-essential but adds value to
your life or it is junk yeah the problem
with this is too often we think we need
something but it's just a want or even
worse yeah I kind of liked it once upon
a time but now it's getting in the way
yeah well if something gets in the way
it is clutter and our ability to let go
is what enables us to move forward with
the things that are necessary now she
does have one line at the end of this
this one here separating once from need
she says Needs have to stay you get to
choose about the once and so what I
would say is even the needs you can
consider removing them sure from your
life yeah because temporarily depriving
yourself of something might teach you
that you actually don't need it at all
yeah number number four on the checklist
is look for the joy A good rule of thumb
is to keep things you know to be useful
or believe to be useful in the words of
William Morris if you want a golden rule
that will fit everything this is it have
nothing in your houses that you do not
know to be useful or believed to be
beautiful
I think that's great especially when we
talk about minimalist architecture we're
going to talk about this on the maximal
episode this week Ryan we're going to
talk about the eight elements that
really go into minimalist design and
that encompasses it fairly well yeah and
quite often it's beautiful through
subtraction the bones are the beauty of
Simplicity number five on the minimalist
checklist is clear your schedule
we often don't think about calendar
clutter but one of the ways we fill up
our lives with unnecessary Stress and
Anxiety is through cluttering our
calendars sure we've got a lot of
physical clutter in our homes our cars
our offices our garages our attics our
basements our storage lockers but then
we also start cluttering our calendar
with meetings and appointments and not
there's nothing wrong with any of those
things nothing wrong with material
possessions just like there's nothing
wrong with meeting with friends family
businesses co-workers whatever but we're
constantly filling up our calendar it's
because we're well we feel that we need
to do more in order to be fulfilled yeah
that rarely works that's why I yeah
that's why I got interest in the
minimalism I wanted my time back and uh
so yeah that's a great step that's uh
that's something that I was able to
achieve like I remember
you know selling my uh my condo and
getting rid of my car payment I was like
oh wow like I could start clearing my
calendar now because I don't need to
work this crazy job these crazy hours to
pay for all these debt payments yeah now
recently you talked to me about some
calendar clutter you were having you had
missed an appointment or two yeah and
you realized like well wait a minute
maybe I need to restructure this a bit
you want to talk about that at all uh I
don't know what the release talk about
except yeah I had this week where I was
um committing to certain things and
totally
just slipped my mind like after five
o'clock my brain says hey man you don't
have to do much right now like you know
just like you're on you're in Coast mode
right now like it's towards the end of
the day all you got to worry about is
eating and getting ready for bed hanging
out with Mariah yeah um but like we're
you know one of the things I forgot I'm
sitting there and uh Mariah's like oh my
God we're supposed to meet so and so at
Topgolf so she forgot too yeah she
forgot to we we are um we are Dilly and
Dolly I don't know which one's which but
uh but yeah we we uh God love us but
yeah we both forgot and I'm like and I
feel like such a jerk man like I call my
friend like I'm so sorry we forgot I'm
on my way I'm gonna be about five
minutes late they were like no we'll
just we'll just plan another time I'm
like all right like fair enough like
that's fine um but yeah so what I've had
to do I mean as far as restructuring
goes I gotta set an alarm for things I
did this yesterday I had a meeting at
five o'clock
um as soon as I got up in the morning I
checked my calendar I always do this I
check my calendar that was what was
helping me prevent things uh Missing
things
um by checking my calendar but now
apparently if there's anything at 5 p.m
or after I have to set an alarm so I get
up I check my calendar if I have an
appointment at 5 PM or after I set my
alarm for like 4 30 or whenever I need
to leave or whenever I need to think
about leaving
um yeah so that that it was great
because that you know yesterday that
alarm went off at 4 30. I'm like oh yeah
I got that meeting so yeah sometimes I
get restructure a little bit but uh not
I'm I'm not over committed
um but I will say I do often over book
sometimes so you know and Mariah is
really good at helping me not overbook
so you know someone will be like hey do
you want to do something on this date
and I'm like yeah because you know the
seven the Enneagram seven and me maybe
more the glutton for fun and experiences
yeah I'm like yeah let's do it and
Mariah's like hey
um you are gonna be in Nashville that
weekend oh yeah that's right no never
mind I can't do that
well here's a few things I've done to
help with my own calendar clutter
because I suffered a lot from calendar
clutter during my corporate day
specifically I would have virtually
every 15 minute block just blocked out
and I thought it was keeping me what
organized just like my basement was
organized with lots of bins and boxes
and labels and I was doing the same
thing with my calendar it was just a 2d
version of my basement basically yeah a
few things that have helped me number
one most important saying no much more
frequently our friend Derek sivers talks
about hell yeah or no and if a decision
is not a hell yeah then I say hell no to
it the other thing that's helped me out
a lot is something similar to what you
do I just at each each night before I go
to bed I will check my calendar before
we do something called that we call
setting the stage so at home we'd spend
five or ten no more than 15 minutes
usually it's three four five minutes
just resetting the house if there's
anything that's left out we put it up
and it sets our next morning up for a
stress-free calm morning but then I also
know if I have to get up early for
something you know if we're going to
record a podcast that day or whatever it
might be if I need to leave the house
early that way I know the night before
so I can plan for it I'm not I'm not
blindsided by it if I don't do that
there was a time a few months ago where
I didn't do that I forgot to do it that
night and of course what happened I
missed the inner interview that you and
I were supposed to do but then I paid
you back the following month when I
forgot the other interview yeah we're
just good friends like that that's right
we just said Thank God there's two of us
all the irony the irony of all of it oh
yeah number six on the minimalism
checklist unplug everything you don't
have to unplug forever but scheduling
regular screen free time can restore
your perspective and bring more joy to
your simple life I guess a screenless
Saturday every once in a while or every
Saturday yeah it's useful it's great
it's peaceful you know Bex and I just
moved into this new home with Ella and
I've been surprised by how not compelled
Ella is to get on her tablet anymore
because she has access to more nature
she has access to arts and crafts we
have her right now in this clay pottery
camp that she really enjoys going to and
so it's apparent to me that our screens
are often a pacifier for kids and for
adults we pacify ourselves with our
glowing screens yeah on the maximal
episode this week someone asked a
question about
about well you don't have internet at
home how do you what do you do with your
time then which is an interesting
question but I'll talk to you about some
of the things that I do no one would
have asked that like 20 30 years ago
yeah even 10 years ago you would have
probably gotten far fewer requests like
that yeah to explain yourself and how
could you possibly survive without it
well it's really easy it's really
peaceful we'll talk about that number
seven schedule rest so this is one thing
that if you do have calendar clutter
maybe something else that can help you
out is scheduling in blocks and you'll
see this on my calendar Ryan and I share
a calendar and he'll see this on my
calendar from time to time where it just
says jfm personal time and it's two
hours five hours whatever and I'm
generally scheduling nothing
intentionally now I avoid putting
anything on my calendar anyway but there
are other times where I just want to
block off time and it's jfm quiet time
and that's it yeah so scheduling rest
number eight make it your own Simplicity
is not competition I think that was
early on when you when we stumbled into
minimalism Ryan you saw all these
different minimalists like the extreme
radical minimalism oh man here are the
75 things I own the hundred thing
challenge oh yes yeah uh Dave Bruno
which is a great book great book and he
in there is able to illuminate the fact
that it's not about the hundred things
it's about temporarily depriving
yourself to find out what is important
what is clutter and getting rid of the
Clutter for him and his family but then
we saw even more extreme minimalists
like Colin Ryan who owned 52 things and
it got down to Nina Yao who I think at
one point owned 15 things yeah it did
start to become a competition at a
certain point I don't know when but yeah
um if it was if you know being a
minimalist is owning as little as
possible then there are monks who are
killing us in the game you're destroying
us
that's true and so Ryan and I aren't
ascetics we aren't monks we're not
trying to live with nothing in fact my
quality of life would go down
considerably if I lived with nothing
yeah the question is what is appropriate
for me and if it's a competition then I
may be depriving myself of what's
appropriate because oh my gosh Ryan
doesn't own uh this bed and so I I guess
I can't own a bed either whatever it is
right or this person doesn't own a couch
so now I'm not allowed to own a couch
yeah or this person doesn't have a
coffee Kettle so now I can't own a
coffee Kettle yeah and now I'm depriving
myself of something that would actually
add value to my life comparison is the
killer of Joy amen and yeah we gotta
yeah I'll tell you the one thing I own
though that like that I'm a little um
frustrated that I absolutely need it is
my bed because like I've gone camping a
couple times over the last uh six months
and do I my back is so bad I didn't
realize how bad my back was yeah and so
I went camping and then I wake up the
next morning I'm like oh my God God like
I could do maybe two nights of it but
Beyond two nights like I don't I don't
get good sleep I hurt in the morning but
there's like this resentment when I lay
in my and I even got like the the
adjustable bed yeah I'm like oh man I'm
glad I have this so I can get some good
night rest but I hate that I I'd need it
yeah I absolutely need it anyway well
there are a couple more items on the
minimalism checklist here number nine is
remember your relationships I would
simply say love people and use things
because the opposite never works number
10 enjoy more and less more time more
freedom and more room to breathe less
stuff and less stress less to organize
store and take care of less hassle less
Hustle I dig that that's from uh Melissa
Wilkins we'll put a link to that in the
show notes she has a Blog as well put a
link to her blog in the show notes and
she has a book called permission granted
Ryan before we get into our questions I
want to talk to you about five questions
that I want to ask you yes so I thought
this would be appropriate since we're
talking about
well we're talking about the minimalist
checklist on this episode we're talking
about simple ways to simplify and one of
the ways to simplify is to avoid
bringing new things in yeah to our lives
because that can become a problem if you
simplify everything you let go of
everything but then you just buy
everything new and you amass a new horde
over the course of months or years
because hoarding or clutter doesn't tend
to happen overnight yeah it's over a
period of time well you know when you
open up space
it's like calling for us to fill it
that's right so it's yeah it's very easy
to do so we have this at the
minimalists.com this is five questions
to ask before buying we'll put a link to
this in the show notes and also in here
you can find the these five questions on
our website if you go to the
minimalists.com wallpaper you can have
them on your phone so whether you're at
the store or getting ready to shop
online you can have it as a desktop
wallpaper as well you can download these
five questions and there's a nice little
reminder before you decide to buy
something new the first question to ask
yourself if you're getting ready to buy
something new is can I afford to part
with this money here's a hint if you
have to charge it to a credit card you
can't afford it amen now that is not an
insult there are many things that I
can't afford because I simply don't have
the cash for it yeah now why don't I
want to go into debt for those things
because maybe I feel like I really want
it now or maybe I feel like I even need
it right right now well the truth is I
don't want to punish My Future Self for
my current impulses I don't want to
punish My Future Self I don't want to
borrow from my future in order to
placate myself right now yeah the second
question to ask is can I pay the actual
cost yeah Ryan you would talk about the
true cost of an item oh sure I mean
there's the cost of storing the thing
maintaining the thing watering the thing
charging the thing changing the
batteries and the thing yes changing the
oil and the thing refueling the thing
repainting the thing taking care of the
thing protecting the thing yeah there's
so many other costs that like we just
don't ever think about yeah and so it
goes beyond the price tag right we pay
for an item then we end up paying for it
over and over again the storing of the
thing the worrying about the thing the
psychological and emotional costs of our
thing are immeasurable so we have to
choose really carefully what things we
bring into our lives because we can't
afford every thing yeah I mean it's
really easy to look at the price and say
yeah I can afford that
um that's quantifiable but like all
those other costs that I mentioned like
that's those are the emotional and the
psychological costs like those are
really difficult to quantify so yeah
we've got to be real careful yeah number
three
will it add value to my life
so for me it must serve a purpose if I
buy something that's going to serve a
purpose or it's going to amplify or
enhance my experience of life and if not
I have to be honest with myself and I
have to leave it on the Shelf yeah
because if it's not going to add value
to my life
for an extended period of time
then it's
leaving it at the store
is like letting go in advance yeah tweet
that
tweet that Professor Sean
hey uh I really like the joy does it
bring joy it was an or server purpose is
that what yeah that article was saying
oh the article earlier was talking about
whether or not it is it is it's either
useful or it's beautiful yeah useful or
beautiful that's what it is I love that
that's uh and you're both Ryan oh thanks
man
here's the next question for you
question four
what are the alternatives
in other words what is is this the best
use of this money right so say I do want
to buy a hundred dollar widget because
you know me I love some widgets you love
widgets I have so many widgets 13 of
them
um anyway I have a whole widget
collection no if I'm getting ready to
buy something and it's 100 bucks and
let's say it is going to add value to my
life that's not a good enough reason to
buy it though if it's useful or
beautiful great that's one of the
questions but it's not the only question
that I'm asking here because if I have a
hundred dollars that is a finite
resource yeah is this the best use of
this money and if not I'd rather spend
that hundred dollars elsewhere yeah it's
that old Andy Davis line that we love he
has that great song called Good Life and
he said we struggle to pay rent because
jeans are expensive yeah and that
perfectly
summarizes our obsession with
consumerism we're forsaking our needs in
order to get what we want right now and
the fifth and final question to ask
before buying something is
can I get by without it for a while now
doesn't mean you have to live without it
forever right we have something in our
minimalist rule book over at the
minimalists.com rulebook you can
download it for free of the 16 rules
that are in there there's one that we
call the wait for it rule or the 30 30
rule yeah and that basically says hey if
something costs more than thirty dollars
I wait 30 hours to buy it now it doesn't
mean that I can't afford it I have
thirty dollars in my pocket I could buy
it right now right why do I wait then
well I wait because maybe if I think
about it for a day I'll realize that
that was just an Impulse yeah and maybe
I'll be just fine or even better without
it yeah amen
Ryan I want to talk to you about two
quick ways to save money on every
purchase okay so what funds
you know what's funny is I don't do
coupons I know and the reason I don't is
because I have found in my own life I'm
not prescribing this to anyone else but
I have found that in my own life if I
cut coupons save coupons join Rewards or
loyalty programs by and large when I do
those things they actually encourage
more spending of course they do yes they
absolutely do and that's what they're
designed to do right yeah and so I have
two quick ways in Alabama I want to talk
to you about this here in a second as
well so Professor Sean make sure her
microphone is on
so whether it's furniture or appliances
or any non-consumables I the first thing
that I will do is I will incorporate the
30 30 rule that we just talked about
yeah and it costs more than thirty
dollars I'm gonna wait at least 30 hours
I'm going to wait for it and sometimes
the way that I'll do that is I'll put
something in my cart uh if I'm saying
I'm shopping somewhere I want to buy
something online I'll put it in the
shopping cart and then I'll go back to
that shopping cart the next day and I'll
delete all the items or I'm like oh I'm
so glad I didn't buy that thing yeah and
so the 30 30 rule or the wait for rule
helps me avoid the Clutter before it
ever enters my front door or shows up on
my doorstep yeah so that's the first
thing the second thing that I do is I've
I'm much more comfortable now buying
high quality items used sure I'm going
to talk to you in a moment about how I
just sold all of my furniture yeah as we
were moving yeah it was this awesome
experience in fact you know what we can
we can talk about it right now and I
don't think it'll be part of this little
little two-step way to save money
because when Bex and I were moving my
landlord at our apartment meant in La he
came in to do his little walk through he
says I have rented hundreds of
Apartments to hundreds of people and
this is the nicest looking apartment
I've seen who does your interior design
I was like oh I do and he's like what
would it cost to like buy all this
furniture from you I'm like what he's
like seriously if I wanted to buy all of
this furniture everything in here
what would it cost me and so I'm like I
don't know man a lot of this and then I
got a little clingy at first right
because well wait a minute this my
identity is tied up into my my couch and
my my table yeah and you spent so much
time like curating all those things and
it's art and we're going to talk about
that on the maximal episode this week
how the furniture that I enjoy the most
are also they double as art pieces it's
Form and Function absolutely and I think
that's where minimalism really comes
into uh helping us simplify Our Lives is
the form follows function I'm sorry yeah
form follows function right quite often
the opposite can get us into trouble we
have some uncomfortable things but they
look beautiful right or they get in the
way and so we'll talk about that as well
Ryan on the private podcast this week
but I'm now much more comfortable buying
used things I'll give you an example
here as and so as my my landlord Kennedy
said I want to buy everything I said
sure I'll put together a list of
everything that we have in here
thankfully I don't own a whole lot so I
was able to actually just put together a
spreadsheet which he was so impressed by
like it's just a it's just a Google
Sheets it's everyone has access to it
yeah yeah but it's you're on the
spreadsheet King though ah thank you I
remember back in the courtroom I was
concatenating formulas I very much
admired your spreadsheet skills
thanks but
um I just put together a very simple
spread she said hey here are the here's
everything I own and here's what it
would cost brand new now that it's used
here's what I'm willing to sell it to
you for and he was like okay yeah I'll
buy it yeah and then that twinge came
back again and I realized like oh no
but wait maybe and then I realized oh no
here's here's the truth over the last
dozen years or so I've built up this
special superpower and it's called
letting go yeah amen and
I think that you must be willing to let
go of anything
to regain everything you could tweet
that Sean and I think
quite often when we cling to something
it prevents us from Gaining what we want
to gain doing what we want to do
experience what we want to experience
having what we want to have and then
what do we do we cling tighter right I
really liked all the furniture that I
had and it was rather appropriate for
the home that we lived in for the last
five or so years
but it was less appropriate going into
this new sort of forever home or in fact
we're going to talk about forever homes
on the Maxwell episode there's a
question about forever homes right and
what does that mean exactly yeah but Bex
and I found our forever home and what we
realized is like some of these things
wouldn't actually be appropriate we'd be
cramming them into this space because we
don't own much we'll slowly slowly
populate the new space over the course
of the next year or two until it feels
right for us and so here's the second
way to
save money on every purchase we talked
about the 30 30 rule the other way is to
buy things used now the two places that
I I go Facebook Marketplace and I just
found this um
nuguchi
um coffee table which are really
expensive if you buy them new uh he was
a American designer back in the 20s 30s
40s 50s and it's a piece of art it's a
beautiful table but it's thousands of
dollars if you buy it new yeah
and I found a Facebook Marketplace for a
few hundred bucks nice two scratches on
it um yeah there's some character to it
right oh yeah we'll talk about it uh I
think the maximal the Rick Owens video
oh yes but I love it like he's going
through all he's so he's a designer and
he's going through his home uh his
office specifically he was like you know
I moved in here like this
um I haven't painted anything I haven't
refinished any of these like these
little dents and scratches he's like I
love it I love the patina I'm like there
is a charm to it I mean there is dude
the um oh I forget his name in Ohio
famous famous Furniture maker uh
something he's David T Smith I think
okay
um but uh I know people that worked for
him and like you should see the
Contraptions that they have the tools
that they have to create patina on this
furniture I mean you're talking about
like a club with like nails and screws
and like just and they just sit there
and they just they don't beat the hell
out of it but like they sit there and
they like add patina to a little a bit
here a little bit there and yeah or like
um yeah it's crazy man they've really
come up with some unique things to
create this faux patina it sounds like
one of those anger rooms but a very
light version of that yeah have you got
I think you've gone to one of those
haven't you no you know no no I haven't
has an escape room ever turned into one
of those for you for you no dude no but
it's just funny because I remember when
I was a kid I would get so mad that
um I remember it I remember um
fantasizing about anger rooms and it's
just funny how like now they're actually
a thing they are you have to put on like
protective gear and eyewear and then you
have like a bat or a chainsaw I don't
know what you do to go into the room
yeah and we won't put a link to it in
the show notes no we won't but it sounds
like a lot of fun hey with the right
attitude any room can be an anger room
I think the same true same is true with
a calm room yeah or bathroom
uh backs and I my wife uh we were
talking to her podcast which is called
how to love and I was talking about how
I have my dream house now so I I have
this this back house basically it's an
old converted garage it's a small studio
apartment I'm like and it just has a bed
and a table and that's all I need and
she goes a bathroom too right oh it has
a bathroom
yeah anyway
um Ryan the other place I look besides
Facebook marketplaces Craigslist is
still a solid place to look for now this
is part of the hunt you have to know
what you're looking for I'll never get
on Facebook Marketplace and browse yeah
I would discourage myself from doing
that yeah because I don't browse for
anything I'm not looking for if I know I
want something in particular like that
table then I went searching for it now
it may not be available right now but
then what do I do I wait for it back to
the first way to save money because
guess what I can get by without a coffee
table amen and I just set my coffee on
the floor I still have a coffee cup
and a coffee floor yeah yes and and so
it's it's fine to just wait for it
Craig's listing out the place now
Alabama you've been selling some of our
things for the studio here we had some
carryover studio stuff or some things
that just didn't work for our space What
are some of those websites that we've
been using to sell some other things
that are outside I haven't used them
personally but I want to talk to you
about those yeah so there's four cycle
through I used OfferUp as well as
Facebook Marketplace I found that those
are really user friendly and those are
great for local um pickups what's all
for uh exactly so OfferUp is essentially
the same thing as Facebook Marketplace
it's an app that is uh designed for you
to find gently used open box you know
thoroughly used kind of items in the
same way that you would search for
something on Facebook Marketplace they
both offer their own shipping methods
but I've personally found them to be
really good if you're trying to sell and
meet someone in your area like at a
local park or at somebody's house and
things like that you get to choose that
to your comfort level of I'd rather meet
someone uh at a separate location or
just have them come to me kind of thing
yeah so I do like both of those they're
very user friendly they're really great
for communication the other one we use
is eBay I don't enjoy it as much but it
is much better if you're looking to ship
items I found a lot of people that are
on eBay are expecting to have something
ordered and shipped to them not as
successful with local pickup but still a
good resource to have yeah and a niche
one that we use is Reverb like
reverberation reverb.com is really great
for musical instruments I used to work
in music retail and this was one of the
best places that we would recommend
people get most bang for their Buck
they're reselling a guitar or a
microphone for us we're doing some
recording equipment so that's the market
for that kind of materials that's people
that are specifically looking for
certain model numbers or brands of
equipment things like that wow and is
there one that you've had more success
selling things on
I I would say OfferUp has been the the
most productive of the apps Facebook
Marketplace gets a lot of inquiries they
have a preset to where you can press a
button and say hey is this still
available yeah you can just kind of
establish that conversation but a lot of
them end up being dead ends I think to
your point because of a lot of people
are going on there and just browsing and
they go oh that looks nice I want to see
that and they press the inquiry and they
never come back again a lot of ghosting
going on there for sure I'm Alabama if
you are buying something from one of
these sites do you find one is the most
user friendly the one that you if you
are looking for a particular item is
there one site that you gravitate toward
I would say that I gravitate towards
OfferUp I have used eBay in the past
I've used that for open box Electronics
like like gently used phones and things
like that but the thing I like about
OfferUp is it allows you to rank the
person that is doing the buying and
doing the selling kind of similar to
Airbnb so you are ranked by how you know
how well were you on time how friendly
were you how communicative were you how
reasonable and things like that so you
can get a snapshot of the person that
you're potentially going to be doing a
sale with or selling to to see hey are
they reputable about showing up on time
are they really good at communicating or
do they kind of flake off on you a
little bit or are they not super nice to
to bargain with and haggle with I really
like that feature because you you get an
idea of the kind of person that you're
going to meet up with and you you have
those expectations at the front man I
know this sounds like black mirrish but
I wish everyone had a customer rating
and you could just like go to someone's
profile and it told you like how good of
a customer are they this would have
helped so much in the retail space I
have this like oh this is probably not a
good uh a good good idea meaning like
like morally good
um so I was at I was in Chicago Mariah's
sister was uh waiting on some tables and
there was just this one particular table
that was just like talking down
entitlement
um just intentionally going out of their
way to be a crappy customer and I'm like
I want to own a restaurant one day just
so I can kick people out who act like
that or charge them more like charge
them more right exactly yeah like you
you can either pay twice as much or
leave but but you can't you cannot treat
my staff that way yeah yeah well no I I
guess you wouldn't want them to at any
price to treat your staff that way of
course if someone came in here with a
million dollars and they're like hey we
want to be mean to Mallory right yeah I
tell them to kick rocks I'd be like
Mallory we'll split it
[Laughter]
but you're right though like there's no
price that yeah there would be but uh
well I do want to rate you real quick
since we're talking about this you go
first so if you were right me as as a as
a customer or a friend or whatever I
will give you
4.99 Stars oh I don't know because no
one's perfect out of out of five stars
yeah I thought it was out of a hundred
no no 4.9 is ours and it's only to mess
with your OCD or no I should have ranked
you 5.01 that's what I'll rank you 5.01
I mean I would uh 10 out of 10 scale
Ryan I personality wise you're a 10.
looks wise you're a I am an adjustable
six yeah
yeah
I would say let's move on to our callers
but uh we're running out of time here
although if you do have a question or
comment for a podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com now uh we
have a question from Andrea but we're
going to save that hopefully for the
maximal episode this week Ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your text messages you can text those
questions comments smart remarks to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response so put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place thanks to our good friends
social Jess she set up minimalmaxims.com
for you what a good idea remember she
came to us with that idea I'm like oh my
God you're a genius
it's great because now all the pithy and
it's real simple you just refresh the
site there's just one pithy minimal
Maxim and Ryan can attest to this doing
minimal maximums every week just one is
way more difficult than one might think
yeah because they end up sounding like
faux fundities if you're not careful a
faux profundity and and so Ryan and I
are often like going we're dueling with
our before the podcast with our minimal
maximums because we want them to be
strong and and well tweetable right and
I will tell you this Ryan uh to this
week's question is about minimalist
architecture so I have a pithy answer
for you there but a lot of times these
minimal maxims they you know you go to
the website you can just copy and share
it with you know the friends family
whomever and also the show notes if you
get them sent right to your inbox every
Tuesday or if you're if you text us that
the phone number you gave earlier
937-202-4654 every Monday we'll send you
a Monday morning minimal Maxim we should
have a faux fundity segment oh we're
just like making fun of our own maximum
I'm really good at faux fund of these
yeah like um uh
uh if you've gone too far keep going
[Laughter]
don't don't tweet that podcast
it's funny though because I'll go to
minimalmaximas.com sometimes and refresh
the screen just to kind of look at some
tweets yeah or look at some uh uh you
know pithy answers especially if I'm
having trouble
coming up with a pithy answer I'll just
you know kind of get the spirit of some
of them and sometimes or someone will
tweet at me and sometimes I'm like did I
say that I guess I mean they're quoting
me I must have said it like man that's
good well I I went there about a year
ago and Jess and I cleaned it up because
we had over a thousand thousand minimal
maximums on there yeah and I went
through and I'm like some of these don't
hold up yeah and so I removed probably
600 of them oh wow and there's probably
close to a thousand there now at this
point again but there's a lot of ways to
simplify your life and these are just
little just little reminders and we'll
start your week off each Monday with a
Monday morning minimal maximum just send
us a text you can those texts go to both
of our phones by the way we respond to
as many people as I can we're gonna
respond to Alessia on the podcast
where I live doesn't have any general
plan for the city so everyone's designs
clash and it looks ugly do we need
minimalist architecture or just better
taste so I don't want to prescribe
minimalist architecture to everyone yeah
now I would be in complete Bliss right
I'm a big fan of like brutalism in fact
when we were finding our new home Bex is
more sort of wabi-sabi which is the
Japanese art of imperfection it's like
having one small imperfection somewhere
that adds a human element to an
otherwise more pristine space I'm a
bigger fan of like brutalism like like
pretty extreme minimalism with respect
to architecture but if I were to force
that on to everyone it'd be like you
forcing Art Deco onto everyone or those
weird houses like the turrets on houses
and or Victorian style whatever it is
you don't want to force anything onto
everyone right and that's what
regulations do however sometimes when
you go to a place and it seems really
calm I think about Sedona have you been
to Sedona oh yeah and so they don't
allow like I think it's the only
McDonald's in the world that doesn't
have the golden arches yeah they have
like this green Arch that conforms to
their City Planning there is a yeah
there's a regulated aesthetic in Sedona
yeah and when we you and I were back in
retail Ryan
I always advocated for more signage and
I was part of the problem I was making
cityscapes uglier with giant pile on
signs Billboards more more signage we
need customers to see where our store is
we need banners out front we need the
dancing waving man right that way we
know that people know where we are but
of course that adds to the chaos I was
adding to the chaos and for that
everyone in Dayton Ohio Cincinnati Ohio
Northern Kentucky Indiana I apologize
here's my here's my epithy answer for
you though Ryan complexity
is ugly
Simplicity is beautiful
now you don't need minimalist
architecture in order to simplify you
can simplify from wherever you are you
can have the craziest most extreme
radical busy architecture and begin to
simplify from there you can have the
most full cluttered home and you can
begin to simplify from there and as you
simplify you start making space not
space for more things but space for more
calm for more peace more tranquility
my fifth answer is this a mad house is
built with bricks of expectations now
there's something we say that I like I
love it man I think it's one of the most
profound things we've come we've come up
with which is low expectations high
standards and you would think when you
say low expectations yeah people often
think like well you know like I mean so
I just shouldn't care about the people I
bring into my life or you know I
shouldn't have these expectations it's
like no you shouldn't have expectations
that good people are going to come in
your life but have high standards of the
people you do bring in your life and the
the home that you have but the thing is
is if I throw my expectations on Mallory
hey Mallory I need you to wear these
other things uh because whatever you're
wearing by the way lovely outfit so I
don't mean that at all no worries
um except for those socks deal with it
they need yeah no actually those are
cool socks
um but but let's say I threw that on her
it's like two things one
um I'm gonna make Mallory do something
that probably goes against your
standards and B I'm and two I'm like
creating this misery for myself when she
doesn't or the opportunity to be
miserable when she doesn't eat uh meet
my my expectations so yeah lower lower
your expectations raise your standards
because yeah you're going to be
miserable if you're just hurling your
expectations on everyone I love what
you're saying there too because in a way
whenever we have an expectation that's
the mad house part of your your middle
Maxim here we're punishing ourselves for
other people's decisions right and so if
I was serious about the socks I actually
um you know six out of ten but that's
another joke calm down people
um all right so 10 out of 10. yeah we
got to make sure that our audiences were
joking Jordan yeah blur out her feet on
the podcast please
uh yeah anyway
um if I were now upset about her socks
I'm punishing myself for her decision
yes now it doesn't mean that I can't
have a certain standard where it's like
hey no everyone in here has to wear
shirts okay if Professor Sean shows up
without a shirt as hunky as he is
I don't want to see it I don't want to
impose that onto anyone else I'm really
glad you just told me that because I
have plans
all right everyone needs to wear a shirt
except hunky Professor Sean yes it did
so um I don't want to punish myself and
the best way to punish yourself is to
have expectations of others and there
are you know I treat that too yeah I
like that you're bringing this up
because yes we do expect everyone to
come to the studio fully clothed so I
mean that is it but that's a low
expectation yes
um how they're clothed is that would be
a little bit higher of an expectation
which again would lead to a mad house
yes indeed well Ryan I got four things
for right here right now usually I say
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists we're still
we're so minimal this is uh extreme
minimalism dude uh when we were flying
uh to Nashville for the Dave Ramsey
stuff the stewardess she was like
looking at your laptop she was like oh
and I like went to the bathroom she was
like all right I saw you guys have a
podcast what you podcast about so then I
explained over the minimalist and you
know so that's about 45 minutes yeah I
know I need to start saying that
um she was like wait and you live in L.A
I'm like yeah she was like how does that
sync up with your philosophy being
minimalists and living in Los Angeles
I'm like ma'am everything we do is
steeped in irony like no matter what no
matter what we do like it's yeah
everything we do is steeped in ironing
there's a giant blanket of irony that I
just wrapped myself in each night yes
the first thing right here right now the
final days of minimalism I waited well
we sent this out if you're on our email
list you already know about this but
every chapter has an ending Ryan and
Well on June 15th 2022 yeah minimalism
our first documentary
minimalism a documentary about the
important things exited Netflix yeah and
I want to read this essay really quick
it's a short one we'll put a link to it
in the show notes as well it's called
the final days of minimalism this
particular chapter began nine years ago
in late 2013 when the minimalists teamed
up with director matthewvella and our
friends over at Spire media as well uh
Dave and Jeff and Marla at the time
um they uh they helped us with the film
right and so we teamed up with Matthew
available to film our first documentary
we didn't know what it would be called
who would be in it or how it might
influence the world we simply piled into
Ryan's Toyota Corolla and filmed a
thousand hours of tour stops minimalist
interviews and sunset time lapses
inside joke it took two years but after
nine grueling iterations we finally
produced a film we were proud of yet
Netflix and every other streamer turned
us down so we released minimalism
independently in 400 Theaters in the U.S
Canada Australia I would not do that
again but that's that's a different
conversation it sounds impressive but uh
yeah
and uh it was the number one Indie doc
that year which was fascinating right
and talk about that here so to our
astonishment it was the number one Indie
doc of 2016. it also won awards at
several film festivals we returned to
Netflix with these triumphs but the film
was quote too different
it didn't conform to a formula so they
rejected us again in fact everyone
rejected us but
we didn't let that stop us we released
minimalism online in 2016. again we were
surprised it climbed to number one on
iTunes and stayed there for weeks that
summer
this online success restarted the
conversations with Netflix they soon
licensed the North American rights
through a distributor minimalism debuted
on their platform on December 15 2016.
the timing was perfect at that moment
Netflix was the dominant streaming
service and many people were looking to
simplify especially during the
consumeristic holiday season the
kindling we provided allowed Netflix to
spark a conflagration hundreds of media
outlets and dozens of famous people
shared the dock with their audiences
tens of millions of people watched
minimalism the movie and the movement
trended for months it's so funny if you
go look at Google Trends now and you
type in the word minimalism you look at
December 2016. through the roof yeah
it's just I mean this giant Apex there
wow and in the years that that followed
that as well it's just this giant search
for minimalism and it was because of our
film and Netflix sort of that giant
conflagration there right and so the TR
the film tapped into the cultural
Zeitgeist exposing a general
dissatisfaction with materialism
the attention and impact were
overwhelming so much so that Netflix
licensed the worldwide streaming rights
in March 2017. setting 190 countries
Ablaze with simple living minimalism
performs so well that in 2019 Netflix
renewed the worldwide rights for three
more years they also purchased our
second dock the minimalists less is now
as a Netflix original but now as those
three years come to an end so does our
agreement with Netflix this is a
Bittersweet moment even though less is
now will be featured at the Emmys later
this month we're actually uh recording
this a couple days before the Emmy so we
don't know what the outcome is but by
the time you listen to this or watch
this you will know we weren't able to
come to an agreement with Netflix as
hard as we tried to keep minimalism on
their platform yeah I think this is
happening with a lot of streaming
services right now there are layoffs
there are certain things that are
happening it's not unique to Netflix
Netflix is the biggest streamer out
there still yeah but as we know the
stock market has tanked significantly
and unfortunately Netflix at this time
I'm sure they'll be fine long term but
right now their stock price is down
pretty substantially and so working out
anything with them uh has proven to be a
bit more difficult this year uh not that
it hasn't been great because it has
there we go you had a few days left to
watch minimalism One Last Time on
Netflix well you don't want any more
yeah that's gone yeah we'll tell you why
here in a second now let's be clear this
isn't a bad thing it's merely the end of
a chapter and the beginning of a new one
we'll eventually seek a new streaming
home for minimalism but in the meantime
you'll be able to watch it on demand via
iTunes Amazon or Vimeo you can find all
the Links at minimalismfilm.com vimeo's
the best though yeah the Vimeo version
has six hours of bonus interviews yeah
and so it's like 20 extra videos you get
there yeah for the same price as if you
were to buy it from iTunes or wherever
else this is a chance for us though to
say big thanks to Netflix yeah and to
everyone the tens of millions of people
who watch the film amen the last six
years yeah yeah this is not a yeah this
is not a knock on Netflix we really are
grateful that they yeah gave us these
opportunities yeah you changed our lives
and you changed the lives of millions of
people yeah and we are so grateful for
that I mean in fact the film changed a
lot of lives
but you all Netflix and the people who
watch changed our lives just as much
yeah I never thought we'd be doing all
this with the podcast we originally
started this podcast to promote the film
and ends up that the film promoted the
podcast it was a really beautiful
accident nothing works out how we think
it's gonna work out people I don't know
why the big question that I get asked
all the time that um I need to figure
out a way to process it internally
because it bugs me every time someone
asks me so what are the minimalists in
10 years
what are you guys going to do with five
years from now it's like I don't even if
I had a goal like it's it's going to be
completely different in 10 years yeah I
mean the honest answer to that and I
think we need to become more comfortable
with this in general is I don't know
yeah and I don't know where three of the
most freeing words in the English
language amen yeah because I don't need
to cling to the answer yeah I even do
this with parenting now I was talking to
Bax about this on how to love like Ella
our daughter doesn't get a whole lot of
answers from me but she gets a lot of
questions from me because it's so much
more important yeah when you're teaching
someone to not give them the answer yeah
but to allow them to find the answer do
you think I should start asking the
question back to whoever asks me that
and be like what are you gonna where are
you gonna be in 10 years no no I no I
mean to me like it's not an interesting
question right no and so to me it's not
even a real serious question no because
none of us know where we're going to be
and so I never answered answer an
unserious question with something
serious Jordan I have the uh answer that
you need to say I'm ready is we're the
minimalist in 10 years well 10 years
older
you're a genius you're a genius so by
the way this does not affect our other
film that's on Netflix it should be
streaming in perpetuity it's worldwide
it's called the minimalists less is now
so if you want something else to share
with your friends and family who have
Netflix netflix.com the minimalists
takes you right there I got a few more
things right here right now Ryan I want
to go over with you that was just one of
four yeah these are much quicker a brand
new month is here it is July we have a
hundred free local meetup groups in a
hundred different cities we also have an
online City that meets online if you
want to connect with people locally in
your area
minimalist.org they're free local meetup
groups we're not in charge of them we've
handed them over to you and we want you
to talk about different types of clutter
and easing the Clutter what are we
talking about this month Ryan we're
talking about uh finances minimalist
finances uh Financial clutter yeah
Financial clutter so yeah uh There's No
Agenda with these the only thing is like
we we give a topic and um you know
probably the the groups are going to
cover that but not necessarily but I
guess what I'm trying to say is think of
this as uh meetup.com for minimalists
yeah that's kind of what it is or
aspiring minerals people who want to
simplify their lives you don't have to
be a minimalist to join
minimalist.org these are just people who
are interested in simplifying whether
simplifying your career you're
simplifying your finances you're
simplifying your stuff you're
simplifying your relationships you can
find other open-minded people in your
area where you discuss things online and
then you meet locally occasionally
speaking of meeting locally Ryan and I
and our good friend TK Coleman we just
started something called the Sunday
Symposium heck yeah now I'm a little
hesitant to even mention that on this
podcast Because by the time this comes
out the first one is sold out almost
certainly but you can get on the wait
list over there yeah so it's only
limited the first 200 people yeah it's a
free event or you can donate to help us
pay for the venue and to pay the staff
there as well
sundaysymposium.com it's a simple
gathering for simple people all beliefs
ideologies are welcome all non-beliefs
are welcome as well all ages you can
find all the details over at
sundaysymposium.com we'll put a link to
that in the show notes this is happening
in Los Angeles so if you're anywhere in
Southern California we're going to try
and turn this into a regular thing maybe
it's a monthly Meetup where we're all
getting together we'll have a talk we'll
have special guests we might even have
some special secret musical guests uh
there as well we'll do a discussion
we'll do audience q a and each one's
going to be a little bit different we're
going to build this local community
we're going to go small it's not about
reaching the most people it's about
going deep with this community of people
locally if you'd like to join us you can
get on the wait list over at
sundaysymposium.com and finally real
quick how to write better I teach this
class two or three times a year it is
opening up this weekend 48 Hours only
first hundred students over at how to
write better.org myself and Professor
Sean we are well we'll teach you how to
write better how to write good words
we're originally going to call it how to
write gooder like sort of ironically
yeah but it would have been funny to
like you me and Professor Sean that's it
and so it's a four-week online class
first hundred students only how to write
better.org if you're interested or you
can go over there and you can just
download the free ebook as well it's
called 15 ways to write better
Alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi this is Molly from Salt Lake City I'm
calling the chip regarding managing the
collecting impulse one strategy I have
used is to make friends with people who
share the same hobby or collection and
do regular exchanges with them so you
get the thrill of having a new item but
then when the throw wears off you just
return it to the other owner and you can
get another new item when you get it
back
hi this is Tara from Seattle and I was
just calling
um in reference to Molly when she was
talking about her trophies uh one cool
thing that I did was I took all the
little nameplates off and I kept them
all like in a scrapbook
um you could do that or you could even
put it in a shadow box with your metals
or just set them up and take a really
cool picture and then keep that
otherwise Chuck the trophies and you
know just enjoy the memories but let
them go all right y'all before we get
into our added value segment this week
here is a thoughtful comment from one of
our lovely patreon subscribers Sarah
says new Patron here I'm a huge fan I
found your podcast through the pandemic
and found immense value in it thank you
I replaced my YouTube premium
subscription with your private podcast
I'm listening to the private archives
right now while grounding outside with a
cup of coffee
I love it we've gotten similar messages
that I'm getting so much more value you
know I'm spending five bucks or 10 bucks
if you want the video version of the
private podcast with five bucks it's
like I'm getting so much more value from
this than I would from AMC Plus or CNN
plus which rip low blow Millburn too
soon too soon Hulu Netflix whatever if
you need to cancel a subscription
because you want more of less you can
join us over at patreon.com the
minimalists and thousands of other
open-minded minimizers like you for our
added value segment this week let's
listen to a track from 070 Shake she's
got this new album out Ryan the album is
called you can't kill me and the song is
called body and it's I don't even know
how to describe it because there's a
hip-hop vibe to it
but it's sort of like this surreal pop
punk music
and the way that I've summed it up is
basically like if there was a female
radio head that made an album with Talib
quality and shade
I mean no one shot day let's be honest
here but
it's stunning so enjoy the song it's
called Body by 070 Shake by the way Ryan
we got a bunch more surprise questions
this week like how does minimalist
architecture influence more intentional
living what should I look for if I want
to buy my forever home when does
minimalist architecture become brutalist
and how does it affect how we interact
with public spaces plus a million more
questions about minimalist architecture
for the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description to subscribe
you'll also get a personal link so that
our weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app and you get access
to all of the minimalism archives
patreon.com the minimalists you can
follow the minimalist on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook or Twitter at the
minimalist if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists.com
on behalf of Ryan Nicodemus from Alabama
pot podcast Sean Jordan no more
Professor Sean social justice Danny
unknown post-production Peter Emma The
Immigrant not a very minimalist team you
guys got here what is going on and the
rest of our team like Jeff and Dave and
TK yada yada yada thanks so many of you
Ryan it used to be so simple roll the
credits
my name is Joshua Phillips Milburn if
you live here today with just one
message
please let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening yo we'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]